[Music]
good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation let's bring out our
speakers Peter Schwartz and Ralph Cabana
the format is not a debate that is it's
not going to be a deal where you were
anybody but I guess your inner most
thoughts decides who won and who lost
you do get to choose who goes first we
will get to that in a minute the format
is as follows whoever goes first will
stand up and hold forth on their topic
and their point of view for 15 minutes
and we'll be pretty strict about that 15
minutes so that so we're even then the
second speaker in interview mode draws
that person L even more know on their
point of view and then the second
speaker has the job of summarizing the
first speaker's viewpoint to the
satisfaction of the first speaker who
has to say that's right you got it I
can't believe it but you got it and then
the roofers bolts and it goes the other
way it's that clear at that point we'll
be collecting your questions and we'll
start to get into more interaction
completely here now first we decide who
goes first this will be a show of hands
you're welcome to shout if you want it
won't make any difference we're just
looking at hands and how many you want
Ralph Cabana to go first all right
put your hands down how many want Peter
Schwartz to go first
what can I interesting what is this
telling us okay let me uh let me just
say a little bit about well the Schwartz
is collecting his thoughts now they
realizes he's not in the repulsed mode
Schwartz's well he wasn't royal
dutch/shell for five years so he's got
oil company experience
he speaks richly with people in
government all over the world in
corporations all over the world not from
profit corporations foundations as well
but I will tell you what most
introducers don't do which is that he
was SDS when he was a student yeah so
immensely the Polytechnic Institute then
he was a volunteer in the Peace Corps
and I first met him at an Earth Day kind
of event that he helped organize at UC
Davis he has green credentials he was on
the board of Rocky Mountain Institute
this a longtime friend of Amory Lovins
and he has been in the thick of energy
for basically his whole career
Ralph cavana who will go second is from
Yale trained as a lawyer there and is
the energy specialist with the Natural
Resources Defense Council which for many
of us is the most respected
environmental organization going it
bases what it does on real science on
real technology and it really knows how
to make politics work and it's a real
honor to have him here tonight as well
these two know each other and they know
each other's strong points and weak
points and they go on collaborating and
competing in future so this is part of
an ongoing story starting with Peter
Schwartz
Thank You Stuart and and I want to thank
long now
my colleagues and especially Ralph who
is as Stuart said an old friend and and
I must say I want to thank all of you
I'm astonished
I thought maybe 12 people might show up
tonight and I know many of you along now
regulars and all so I'm very pleased
that you've all chosen to come and join
us this evening because it's a very very
very important issue that we're talking
about here and Ralph and I have been on
the same side on many many issues over
many years and will be again on other
issues but on this one I think we have
some disagreements and I think that's
what we're here to talk about because I
think the reason we need to use nuclear
power is that the risks of really nasty
climate change much sooner than we think
is much greater than is widely believed
and that that climate change is at least
in part driven by our rising use of
fossil fuels and especially coal and oil
and that that in turn is being driven by
rapidly growing developing countries
especially countries like China so in my
view we need every alternative to coal
and oil and we can't afford to leave off
the table anything particularly since
the risks are that are if nuclear power
in particular are likely to fall so the
risks of climate change are very great
and the risks of nuclear power are
declining so that's the the fundamental
position now before I get into the
climate change part of this story
there's one small piece of the story
that is worth spending at least one
minute on but I suspect Ralph and I will
agree on this and are not going to spend
much time on this and that's the oil
issue because of course oil is another
source of hydro car
co2 but in fact I think this issue is
going to be pretty much taken care of by
itself because over the next 50 years
we're gonna run out or we're gonna hit
the peak and it's going to go down the
pessimists think the peak is now the
optimists think it's maybe 30 or 40
years in the future I count myself as
one of those but in any event we're
going to have to make a transition away
from oil over the next half-century no
matter what irrespective of what our
issues are about climate change or
anything else
and furthermore that as we begin to feel
the pressures of that running out the
price of oil is likely to go up so we'll
have the benefit of rising prices to
force us to change our behavior even if
it's not smart enough to do so on our
own so by and large we're going to move
away from oil as a transport fuel we've
already done it in electricity but there
is a further implication for climate
change because this is where it leads us
next is that in fact many of the
alternatives to oil involve electricity
in one way or another that is we may use
electricity to charge batteries on cars
though I think that's less likely more
likely is we'll use electricity to
produce hydrogen which we'll use as a
transport fuel and that may require a
great deal of electricity so the shift
away from oil is also likely to increase
the amount of electricity that we use
and we're going to have to make the
shift away from a loyal in any event the
real issue here is electricity and the
real issue behind it the thing that we
are most concerned about is climate
change and the conventional wisdom on
climate change is that basically what we
have is a situation of partly natural
but mostly human induced mostly by the
use of fossil fuels we are seeing a
gradual rise in the temperature of the
earth and that this will take place over
the next several centuries and will rise
maybe three four five degrees a century
and we're not going to like the
consequences especially if you live in
the Maldives or Bangladesh places like
that which will progressively disappear
on the rising seas now that could happen
that's possible but I think there's a
much worse scenario that we face and a
far more likely scenario and that the
science and the evidence is pointing us
in that direction and you get a hint of
it by looking backwards and that is that
what we face is the possibility not of
several centuries of gradual global
warming but abrupt climate change that
is rapid changes in our climate as we've
experienced many times in the past
changes of 510 degrees over the course
of a decade not centuries and that it
could become very volatile and that that
warming in fact oddly enough could
trigger cooling and without going into
all the mechanisms by which that happens
gradually as the earth warms you see
what's already beginning to happen polar
ice melting glaciers melting and
so on fresh water flowing into the North
Atlantic affecting the currents that
move huge amounts of heat around the
earth and that gradually produced the
temperate climates that we all
experience in the upper parts of the
earth and northern latitudes if the
earth warms rapidly one of the results
is that we could see the earth cool as
has happened many times before and in
fact the greatest risk we face is not
merely gradual climate change but a
return to the normal climate of the
earth and that's what this is showing us
what you see here there we go this is
the last 10,000 years of human history
all of human civilization we could in
fact settle down when the Earth's
climate stabilized we could have
agriculture we could have the
development of cities and so on all of
that took place in the last 10,000 years
after really serious global warming by
the way you can see this is about 20
degrees centigrade here so it's a lot of
movement this is the normal climate of
the earth very volatile and much colder
the risk that we face by rapidly rising
co2 production in the atmosphere is not
a warmer earth it is a return to the
normal climate of the earth an end to
what we call the interglacial these ten
thousand year periods that happen every
quarter million to half a million years
of relative stability the risk that we
face is that if this happens we face a
very dire prospect and that dire
prospect is very simple this can support
eight billion people this may be two six
are going to have to get off the planet
and the way they get off the planet is
war this is a recipe for war and that's
what I'm most concerned about is that if
we fail to deal adequately with the
abrupt climate change challenge we will
find ourselves in a rapidly declining
carrying capacity of the planet and the
inability to support the people of the
earth now we did a lot of work on this
for the Pentagon a couple of years ago
and what we could see then was the
evidence that this was increasingly
coming true we were already seeing
freshening of the North Atlantic
we were already beginning to see some of
the fluctuations in the current we were
seeing it in the climate history we've
even seen some recent indications in the
last year offshore California the
absence of a salmon season most of the
year was due to the lack of an upwelling
from the Pacific change in the currents
there these are the conditions in early
signs of an abrupt shift and it is not
guaranteed it's a risk it could be wrong
but the risk is rising that that is what
we face so I believe that in fact the
real risk here is that our civilization
is at risk this is not simply a small
matter of a few countries and a shift in
the agriculture pattern of the world
this is our very civilization that is at
risk here so what's driving this climate
change and is there anything we can do
about it I mean some of it is natural
probably but most of the evidence
suggests that it is in fact human
activity that is producing the
particularly rapid change that we're
experiencing now and particularly the
fossil fuels that were burning putting
co2 in the atmosphere and in fact having
now talked before about oil and
transportation fuels and so on and
suggesting that some of those are going
to become part of electricity the story
really is electricity it's how are we
gonna produce the electricity that we
need around the world to light our homes
heat our homes drive our factories and
ultimately probably even drive our cars
without producing vast amounts more of
co2 so it comes down to energy and in
fact how do we produce our electricity
it's more about coal and oil and getting
rid of that and most of that is being
driven by the developing world
that is today's level of co2 output we
produced but most of the growth yet to
come is to come from the developing
countries and you can see it in this
graph here this is the growth in energy
demand over the next 50 years starting
back here in the 1920s and the 30s
what you saw was energy to me energy
production was about a quarter of today
but it was mostly coal
very heavily coal over the last sort of
50 years we've quadrupled our energy use
we've added oil natural gas a lot of big
hydro and a bit of nuclear power to that
if we are very efficient we'll only
double our use of energy in the next 50
years but if we continue the way we're
going right now will again quadruple it
that will add a lot of renewables like
wind and solar but that's a lot of
energy to supply and the blue is the
rich countries the what we call the OECD
the yellow are the developing countries
China India everybody else and as you
can see most of the growth is to come in
those places as the next two billion
people get rich one of the great
achievements of the last decade and a
half is about a billion people climbed
out of poverty in places like China and
India and if we're lucky in the next 50
years another two billion will that
can't be a bad thing that can't be a bad
thing to for those people to climb out
of poverty but if they all live the way
we do we're in deep trouble so where's
all that electricity produced it's
produced by coal today and here's what
would happen in about 30 years if we
don't do something
lots more coal not much more oil a lot
more gas this is the challenge and look
that shows a lot more renewables even
there many fold increase the issue is
the co2 so this is the emissions from
the different fuels and what you see is
a steady increase from coal steady
increase from oil we're going to shift
some of that to coal and even some more
from natural gas the challenge here is
how do we get rid of this particularly
this will begin to get rid of it by
itself and this is the cleanest of the
fuels the challenge we see is in China
there we go
China's energy demand is set to grow
again from about 47 quadrillion BTUs to
about 140 it'll triple if it keeps going
the way it is the challenge is to get it
down here to improve its energy
intensity its energy efficiency and by
the way about what the United States did
between 1975 and 85 so it's not
impossible the problem is that most of
its going to come from coal so what are
they going to do to get rid of that coal
and the coal is really nasty coal in
China it's brown soft coal I'll skip
that one now looking at where the energy
is coming from today this is electricity
and what you see these are all the
different ways to make electricity call
the largest this is renewables of which
most of it is hydro and if you unpack
that other 1% most of that is geothermal
solar and wind is a tiny invisible
fraction today
we need to increase it enormous ly but
it is tiny today so our technology
options are cleaning up coal renewables
nuclear hydrogen and efficiency the
point is that economics will determine
some of it and gradually most of its
going to get more expensive these are
the capital costs of it we're going to
have to do basically all of them and one
way to think about it is what you call
stabilization wedges this comes from Rob
Sokolow at Princeton and basically this
is the line of cart of co2 if we don't
do anything that's what we need to do
cut it and each of these you can think
of as a wedge to reduce it so if you
wanted to do it with wind it would take
2 million 1 megawatt turbines if you
want to do it with solar it'll take
2,000 gigawatts 700 times current
capacity if you want to do with nuclear
you need to do two times current
capacity that's the issue here how much
you have to do if you really want to get
rid of that and begin to lower it does
it work well here's what the situation
is in France versus the world the world
for this GDP that output produces about
half a kilogram of Sidi co2 for every
dollar of GDP using 16 percent of
nuclear for producing electricity France
which is 78 percent produces half as
much co2 so it makes a difference it
adds up it cuts it in half already so
what's the issue with nuclear with our
four issues economics safety waste and
proliferation and the answer to all four
is new technology we've learned a lot
over the last 30 years about nuclear
we've made a lot of mistakes along the
way the technology you've had has been
costly some of it is less safe than it
ought to be and we haven't had a good
solution to the waste problem all of it
is now accessible we can see new
generations of reactors which are both
cheaper and much safer and likely to be
constructed much faster so there are a
variety of new technologies coming of
that sort and critically what we see is
a new fuel cycle the fuel cycle that is
recycling the fuel we're one of the only
major nuclear countries that does not
recycle our fuel so we waste most of our
fuel we only use five percent of it
improved recycling leads you to
6% but the new pyrometallurgical ones
lead you to 94% of the fuel being used
much greater efficiency and the
important thing is in the current cycle
you produce plutonium and lots of high
level waste that we want to stick into
unfortunate places like Yucca Mountain
that won't work the pluto the plutonium
recycling has much of the same problem
with waste and plutonium processing but
the new pyrometallurgical processes no
waste are very little waste and no
plutonium produced so the net result is
safer cheaper no waste no plutonium
problem and you radically reduce the co2
and begin to address the climate change
problem thank you very much
Ralph you have ten minutes to draw Peter
out and you look and use that to get in
whatever points I know that everyone in
the audience wants me to open with the
same question and it goes right to your
introduction and Peter what we all want
to know is was there really an SDS
chapter at Rensselaer Polytechnic
Institute and if so how many people were
in it besides you well actually one of
them may even be here is that feed
rotondo in the audience another mutual
friend embarrassing might I think he was
actually in the chapter and me and Pete
one other guy I want very good I want to
give you a chance to talk a little more
about some issues you had to flash
through very quickly at the end for many
in this audience concerns about nuclear
begin with the issue of proliferation
and the fact that is our mutual friend
Amory Lovins likes to say a civilian
nuclear industry is among the best
possible camouflages for an illicit
weapons program you are talking about to
make a material difference as you've
acknowledged you suggested that we would
need at least 700 more nuclear reactors
worldwide we now have about 400 many
presumably in places with less than
fully stable and effective governments
talk a little bit about your view as to
why we shouldn't worry about that as
much as many of us do I think we should
worry about it I think it's a real issue
so let me say that I think it's not a
done deal it's it's a very real issue we
see it today with Iran it's a perfect
example of what's going on it's happened
with North Korea so it's a real issue
it's a real concern I think part of it
has to do with the actual technology of
the fuel cycle that we use and part of
it has to do with the institutional
mechanisms that manage that fuel cycle
so the current fuel cycles are
particularly vulnerable to proliferation
issues because of the ways in which they
produce the fuel ie
we end up with a fair amount of
plutonium in that process as well as we
end up with some nasty wastes that can
be played with in unfortunate ways so
part of it involves shifting the nature
of the technology of how we process the
fuels today in the United States as you
know we don't be processed at all
most of the nuclear countries do but
even their technology I think is still
not really a very economic and still
produces a fair amount of waste so we
need to move beyond that technology the
last two weeks have go inside
the American there was a very good
article which I could direct them into
all of you on essentially the newer
processes pyrometallurgical processes
that basically enable you to do several
things first of all to capture more of
the energy value of the fuel secondly
radically reduced the amount of
high-level waste so that you end up with
you still have some waste but it's a
fairly low-level waste you don't need to
isolate for thousands of years and third
you end up with no plutonium in the
process of radically reduced it however
you don't get to that for decades so we
have a problem just running the existing
system the way we have it and the
current plans for development so we need
institutional mechanisms probably under
the IEA IAEA the International Agency
for Tomic energy that manages the issues
of proliferation to actually help manage
the fuel cycle so you don't have closed
closed fuel cycles in any of the
countries that you are concerned about
ie where they can capture potentially
the harmful products that they could use
in weapons so we're gonna need much much
stronger much more effective
international institutions than we have
now absolutely a wholly different kind
of reactor a wholly different kind of
waste management and waste disposals
that's right on that point as you know
an Achilles heel of nuclear today and
one of the things that makes it
difficult to move forward as a practical
matter is the political challenge of
convincing any particular jurisdiction
and this is a worldwide problem that
accepting waste that at least on the
face of it looks like a hundred thousand
year problem is a sensible proposition
from the standpoint of local land use
management how would you propose to help
them overcome those understandable
skepticism well first of all I think
we've read it believed to find the waste
problem wrong that is the problem of
nuclear waste is not a problem of
storage for 10,000 years or a million
years or a quarter million years or any
such very long period of time the issue
is storing it long enough that we can
put in a form that we can reprocess it
and recycle it and that is probably
surface storage in very strong caskets
in relatively a few sites not large
numbers of sites ie not at every reactor
but also not one single national
repository probably several and a number
of around the world with it in the mind
that you are not putting it in the
ground forever where it or in theory
forever where it could migrate and leak
and raise all the
of concerns that people rightly have
about waste so you're redesigning the
way in which you manage that waste and
change the nature of the challenge
fundamentally is I think okay Peter on
the issue of how this comes to pass
where the where the 700 reactors come
from would you use government mandates
to get it would I mean talk about how it
would as you know basically the way
reactors come into being in the world
today is that somebody has to buy them
normally that's the electric company
normally there's a competitive process
I'm not aware of any competitive
procurement process any electric
utilities ever run in the world open to
all sources where our nuclear plant won
so what's going to change that well
first of all the truth is in most
countries the decision about power
plants are not a private decision they
are in fact a public decision they are
in fact most countries with the
exception of a relatively few wealthy
countries most of it is public utilities
so it is in fact a governmental decision
in most places now the truth is most
countries are not going to build nuclear
power plants so it really is we're
really talking about 30 or 40 of the
relatively larger countries that are
involved not yeah I doubt that we're
going to have a nuclear power plant in
Guiana be so now you know some of the
larger countries are likely to have a
Kazakh Stan and so on and there's an
example of a country where you could
imagine problems or some of the other
stands I think it is very likely that
what we'll see is first of all most of
this plants that we're going to build in
the next let me say 20 to 30 years will
be in existing sites so we're not going
to be confronting the necessity of
building the further plants that we need
the next hundred and fifty 200 plants
that we need until probably another 30
40 50 years in the future until we've
exhausted all the sites where we can
build at the existing sites in the
United States alone for example we have
probably 30 to 40 sites which were
designed for three and four reactors
that only one or two but is it your view
that government should make these
decisions or would you prefer a more
competitive and entrepreneurial process
like the other issue I've ever heard you
talking and the answer is yes I would
much prefer that in the market oriented
economies did be market competition no
question winners and losers emerge on
the merits absolutely and if the nuclear
plants can't make it and it'll make it
that's it and that's what I you
sooner I don't you interrupt me whenever
I'm supposed to restate his position
compellingly because Peter what what is
I'm at the heart of your concern I I
suspect you have this whole audience
with you on the seriousness of the
climate challenge and on the importance
of doing everything we can to end this
suicidally irresponsible experiment
we're all conducting with the Earth's
atmosphere you believe strongly I take
it one of your what one of your graph
shows is that even you take I know you
take energy efficiency seriously and the
colloquy I want you and I to have for
just a moment is to recognize that
energy efficiency is a resource just
like a power plant absolutely that you
would like to see as much of it
exploited as is available and is a
reliability and other we don't make it
if we don't do it I mean you could get
if the world takes advantage of all
accessible and cost-effective efficiency
its energy needs will still double by
2050 on on that order of magnitude
because of the numbers of people well
total energy is another question
electricity demand electricity to
electricity demand because in part of
the also the shift away from oil to
electricity as a source for transport
fuels but if you turned out to be wrong
about that if the potential for
efficiency were greater if the potential
for inexpensive renewables were greater
if the competitive process yielded a
different set of winners and nuclear
didn't make it I don't sense great
distress on your part of course not
there's no other reason to pursue it in
your mind aside from its potential
contribution to dealing with the risks
of climate change well if it were
cheaper if it turned out to be and it
could then that would be another reason
I either were the economic benefit to
consumers from that so given the
relative cost I mean for example coal
carbon capture and sequestration could
turn out to be very expensive just to
take an example but but I guess what I
want to press him on sure and if it were
cheap and if it were safe and if there
were no proliferation problems I think
the audience would rise as one and
embrace it
but but it has nuclei want to press you
again are you aware of any case where a
nuclear plant in a genuinely open
competition against those other
alternatives we've been talking about
has ever prevailed well it depends what
you mean by an open competition and
prevailed so I'll take that give me the
best illustrate the answer is you're
basically right it is it has been driven
by the government so there's no point in
infact trying to play otherwise that is
in fact what has been happening okay
that it has been driven by policy and
certainly that has been the case until
down there's no question and I think
Stuart then the one other thing I'd like
to ask Peter if I may is you you were
focusing on France is an interesting
example of a jurisdiction with
relatively low carbon dioxide emissions
and presenting a different profile from
the world on average right you ever
looked at another interesting
jurisdiction state of California ah yeah
okay so so at least perhaps an
interesting counter example we can flesh
out first yeah interesting what the the
numbers are here in California all right
you are about to pretend to be Peter
Schwartz I'm Peter Schwartz all right so
as Peter Schwartz and it's a pleasure to
take on this persona and an honor look
we we are participating collectively
Humanity in a suicidally dangerous
experiment with the climate we are
driving up concentrations of greenhouse
gas gases in the atmosphere at
historically unprecedented levels I
think I think the only thing I would
have added to what Peter said was as far
as I know the current levels of
greenhouse gases in the atmosphere at
their highest point in the last four
hundred thousand years maybe the last 25
million there is ample ground for
believing strongly that we ought to do
everything we can to end this dangerous
experiment if we can find a way to do it
at reasonable cost and Peter believes
that the that nuclear power with all of
the constraints and problems that it has
had historically based on existing
technology can essentially change its
spots can make a significant and
meaningful contribution to stabilizing
the atmosphere by dramatically improving
its performance in terms of
cost-effectiveness the proliferation
resistance of the fuel cycle and the
waste disposal problem which he thinks
can be solved by fundamentally changing
the political calculation away from an
effort to dispose of wastes 4gl
logic IRA's into a more plausible
short-term approach based on better
technology for capturing the wastes as a
consequence he asks you to keep nuclear
power on the table I think it's a fair
summary ask the audience to do Stewart
your honor so at the outset I need to
acknowledge that I have since 1979 had
the best job in the entire environmental
community I'm the energy program
co-director for the Natural Resources
Defense Council which bills itself as a
national environmental organization but
let's be serious two of the four offices
are in California a fifth of the
membership is in California I think that
I have heard from a good fraction of it
in the last two weeks giving me advice
on exactly what to do this evening not
all of it consistent I thought the best
suggestion was that I should remind
Peter that solar power is a nuclear fuel
and if he will just expand his
definition a little he'll he'll bring
the audience along with him let me
explain I I have it's my belief and what
I'm going to describe is fundamentally
an optimistic vision which is I think
actually very much like Peters was I
don't think nuclear power is going to
figure in your future not because I'm
afraid of it but because I think there
are much better alternatives of a
lecture I am a little bit afraid of it
and I'll get to that in a moment but but
I believe we can and will do better and
I actually think the state of California
is a wonderful proving ground for doing
better and I'm going to talk a little
bit about that let me give you a sense
of my of my skepticism by the way
without in any way as I said I accept
Peter statement of the problem I think I
take the climate change every challenge
every bit as seriously as he does and I
think he set it out about right we've
got to think about the global challenge
I'd put it this way I think what we have
to do is we have to wean the world from
fossil fuels over the next century Peter
ended a memorable article by reminding
you all that the Stone Age didn't end
when the world ran out of stones and
that's not an impossible proposition and
we've been through things like this
before and so over the next 50 years my
view is that we and I think this is
broadly consistent with where a number
of our climate scientists are we've got
to try and stabilize global
missions and we've got to try to cut us
emissions roughly in half and I don't
minimize the difficulty of doing that
for one instant it's a formidable
challenge and many people who look at
that challenge come to the conclusion
that Peter does that gee we need
everything we need to do everything we
could possibly need all the efficiency
all the renewables all the coal all the
nuclear we do the coal we have to pump
the carbon underground we have to do
everything this I would describe as the
working philosophy of the United States
Congress on every energy policy issue of
consequence over the last 50 years we
have to do everything there is I would
submit to all of you an alternative way
of thinking about this in a world with
limited resources and that is to say
rather than letting governments pick the
winners and losers on the merits which
is an idea that in every other context
would cause the the Peter that I know to
recoil in horror rather than do that
here we ought to be moving toward a
paradigm which is much more comfortable
to the Peter Schwartz I know which is
that what we ought to be setting up is a
what we ought of having government do is
establish the limits the pollution
limits we ought to be having government
say look even as we've done with other
major pollutants we're going to limit
the amount of greenhouse gases that get
emitted and then we're gonna let the
winners and losers emerge on the merits
depending on what the least costly ways
are of achieving that objective that is
an approach we have pursued in other
contexts I would submit it's the
approach we should pursue here and I
want to give you my reasons for think
that if we do nuclear is unlikely to be
among the winners now first of all I
hope this is a kind of disarmingly
reasonable proposition if you take this
stuff seriously the answer surely isn't
have the government decide what
technologies to deploy which hasn't
worked tremendously well in many sectors
all right so have the government do what
it does best which is set reasonable
regulatory constraints and limits and
then let the entrepreneurial genius that
Peter Schwartz exemplifies as well as
anybody I know figure out what to do now
if you do that here's why I'm skeptical
that nuclear emerges among the winners
I'm going to wish away several problems
I'm going to assume that there are no
operational safety issues I'm going to
assume that there are no problems
associated with potential terrorist
attacks or sabotage unreal ative leave
ulnar Abul spent fuel pools although I
worry as many of you do that that's
certainly a temptation out there that
gets bigger as you have more and more
reactors but remember Peter has directed
you to imagine a better reactor
so that's fine I'm gonna wish that away
too I still think we end up with three
big problems as we envision a very
substantial expansion of nuclear the
first is that in order to get to Peter's
world of better reactors you somehow get
to got to get the existing world of
existing reactors you've got to get it
past the waste problem and the waste
proposition really has proved in 1984
the United States Congress passed
legislation to force the state of Nevada
to accept nuclear waste by the year 1998
which seemed like a straightforward
propositions a small state relatively
powerless all of the rest of us want to
do this there's fourteen years let's get
this done for heaven's sake and move on
it's 2006 we are nowhere close to doing
that now I think Peter is right to say
let's change the let's change the value
proposition here instead of getting
highly toxic waste for several hundred
thousand years instead you'll be
accepting waste for a mere century or so
in large concrete tasks but even Peter
Schwartz is going to have a tough time
selling that to the skeptical
jurisdictions that are going to believe
in their heart of hearts that maybe just
maybe nobody's going to want those casks
after the first century and they're
going to be stuck with them indefinitely
or as is the case with the existing
reactors maybe the waste just stays on
the existing sites and piles up I don't
think this is the worst problem that
nuclear power has but it is a formidable
political challenge that nobody's
figured out how to overcome but let's
assume Peter overcomes it and we deal
with that and Yucca Mountain fills to
the brim with the wastes of the existing
reactors and everybody forgets about
this issue when we go forward it still
seems to me that there are two
formidable problems and I was trying to
begin to tease them out as we were
talking together the first has to do
with this issue of the linkage between
nuclear power and nuclear bombs which is
impossible for any of us to escape since
any of us who is watching the daily
coverage of events in Iran and North
Korea can see it I mean Iran and North
Korea's fundamental argument to the rest
of the world is what weapons we're just
building nuclear reactors just like the
United States this is civilian power
what's the problem we're just doing what
all the rest of you are doing and the
problem of course as everybody who is
involved in this recognizes is the
deceptive ease with which those civilian
programs become cover for illicit
activity very hard to police there's no
question
I think that we'd have a safer world in
terms of long-term nuclear proliferation
issues if there were no civilian nuclear
industries for the weapons masters to
hide behind and one of the reasons to
look forward to a nuclear-free era if we
can get to it is that civilian cover
will be gone but here is the final
reason why I think and-and-and the most
important why I doubt that nuclear will
figure in your future and it has to do
with the fundamental self confidence
that I want all of you to feel about the
competition that I suspect many of you
value above the nuclear option in terms
of where you want to see the world's
energy future go the energy efficiency
options the renew I mean to have energy
efficiency and renewable energy appear
as two items on a list is for any of you
who know the diversity of these
technologies and options of course very
misleading and constraining we're
talking about literally thousands of
options we're talking about the ability
to create portfolios combine both out of
efficiency a whole host of renewable
electric generation the biofuels options
that we haven't even started to talk
about yet this evening all I am seeking
in my advocacy and what I'm trying to
accomplish is an equal opportunity for
them to compete against the nuclear
plants and the other options I am a
little bit amused when the issue arises
should nuclear power be on the table or
not nuclear powers been on the table for
my entire life which is spanned most of
the lifecycle it's never been off the
table it has a army of lobbyists in
Washington with funding at least a
hundred times those of every
anti-nuclear activist in the country it
has a hundred and a hundred plus
operating reactors in the u.s. each with
a thousand plus employees it has
university centers across the country it
has a whole army of committee chairs in
the Congress supporting it aggressively
it has freedom for it it has complete
protection or largely complete
protection against accident liability it
has subsidies for licensing subsidies
for siting operating subsidies loan
guarantees for the next generation of
plant I think Peter would be
hard-pressed to think of anything else
one could do right now to put nuclear
even more firmly on the table and yet
this is the extraordinary thing not one
nuclear plant has been ordered and
completed since 1973
I suspect before that before the births
of many in this room
and that is because at least in this
country nuclear has time and time again
failed fundamental competitive tests and
this is I think the fundamental reason
for my confidence that better options
will prevail is that I expect the future
to be a reprise of those competitive
tests now the competitive test in the
future I think Peters right they'll be
carbon constrained that is you'll get
points if you have low relatively low
carbon dioxide emissions and nuclear
will get some points nuclear has been
getting points all its life it still
can't win giving it a few more is
unlikely to change the outcome
particularly since the same kinds of
options the same options with equally
appealing low-carbon characteristics
will be getting the same benefit in
those competitive contexts so what
you're gonna see and you'll see at first
in California as California moves as it
already has toward constraints on carbon
emissions that governor has set
aggressive targets to reduce carbon
dioxide emissions I know Peter and I
celebrate that first move now he's got
to act on it likeliest way he acts on it
is and it's already starting to happen
you begin to put your thumb on the scale
you begin to say we want to develop our
electric options with an eye toward
minimizing carbon emissions today in a
historic moment which I suspect not many
of you have heard about yet so I want to
make sure you're aware of it California
PUC has proposed to limit the total
carbon emissions associated with the
resource purchases of the state's major
utilities and in that process as it gets
underway and yes absolutely that's worth
it that's what the moment I'm going to
ask I'm going to commemorate something
else in just a moment too when I close
that's even more important but what that
reminds us is that we are moving into a
carbon-constrained
era but think about what that has meant
in recent years for California we've
already started to do it did you know
for example that when California
utilities evaluate energy efficiency
against renewables against coal against
nuclear they are required to assign a
penalty a cost penalty to resources that
emit carbon dioxide so nuclear is
already getting a thumb on the scale in
California hasn't made a noticeable
difference yet what has happened is that
we've launched the world's largest
energy efficiency and renewable energy
investment programs and that is frankly
what I think and and here's here's where
I sometimes get into trouble but I want
to bring you this far with me I think
Peters right on one point I think
nuclear gets to compete I don't think we
can say
we want low carbon auctions we want a
fair competitor want to go after all the
cost effective efficiency all the
renewables and we're just going to rule
nuclear out of that competition they
can't possibly should make a showing
worse it makes us sound like we're
scared of the nuclear option it makes it
sound like we think maybe there's
something good out there that might beat
our stuff so we want to keep it away we
want to rule it out
we shouldn't be doing that we should be
we should be saying and meaning we can
take them on and beat them just as we've
taken them on and beaten them for the
last thirty years straight often in
situations if you think about the
remarkable fact of no orders since 1973
we're not just talking about no orders
in California we're talking about the
whole country from the southeast we're
talking about some places which in
ideological terms at least are quite
different from the audience spread out
in front of me this evening and you know
the most important reason for that in
the years since 1973 more than 100
nuclear reactors were cancelled many in
an advanced state of construction not
because protesters went after them but
because the cost spiraled out of control
and the utilities that sponsors those
plants had to eat about 60 billion
dollars most of which they weren't
allowed to pass on to customers that
creates viven and enduring memories and
so somehow you have the interesting
challenge in the United States if you
want a nuclear revival in addition to
everything else I've told you you've got
to overcome that rather vivid and
eloquent history and what I would want
to say to all of you is that I see no
evidence at this point that the nuclear
plants can do it now what Peter is
telling you is imagine a better nuclear
plant and the difficulty with imagining
a better nuclear plant is they will have
to that means the whole the existing
infrastructures not going to be terribly
helpful we're moving to something
completely different the first few are
going to cost a lot more they're going
to create some significant financial
risk the utilities that are being asked
to take on that risk will be bonding
lots of help from the taxpayers of the
United States and this is a message I'll
keep coming back with you on the
resources of the United States right now
the public resources are constrained
there is a limited amount available for
public subsidy of any resource and the
notion that somehow there's going to be
a willingness to make the public
investment necessary to create resources
of this scale and remember this is the
fundamental problem of a nuclear plant
think of how big they are think of how
long they take to build think of how
much of a systems capital and operating
capacity they take up
and they're surrounded by smaller and
nimbler competitors the efficiency
options the renewable options to bring
this home to you I wanted to close with
a hometown example for nuclear activists
over the last quarter century the
institution you most love to hate at
least if you went back to when I started
in already see in 1979 was the bad old
Pacific Gas & Electric Company
the Erin Brokovich utility the people
who couldn't shoot straight the Diablo
Canyon blueprint switchers today today
your hometown utility the Pacific Gas
and Electric Company is the largest
investor in energy efficiency in the
world it will shoot shortly be very
likely the largest investor in renewable
energy and in spend is a result of the
PUC actions on solar this week which
many of you contributed to the largest
investor in solar it's running a
resource procurement program it's
acutely conscious of carbon risk and by
the way if you look at the future that
PG&E is is is now a charting it's not
there's no nuclear and there's no coal
in it of course either what they're
trying to do is to build a future around
efficient use of waste heat in natural
gas applications they're trying to add a
lot more renewables and they're trying
to do more energy efficiency than any
other utility in the world has ever done
and I would submit to all of you that
that's the model and what I want to
close on is there is someone here in
this room who helped start that
revolution at PG&E and it's Carl
Weinberg who's sitting right there is
the former head of R&D it is his
birthday tonight and I would appreciate
it if you at all let him know that you
appreciate it
and so I want you to take away from
these remarks not a sense of a
relentless attack on a particular
technology but a sense of boundless
enthusiasm and optimism about its
competitors and the hope that all of us
together will watch the most effective
international demonstration that those
competitors can and will prevail over
the long term right here in California
thank you
very timely Ralph right on time Peter
well done we don't need to spend
obviously any time on the question of
defining the problem I think we both as
you said you you accept my definition
and I and I don't think you changed it
in any way significantly I want to
explore a few issues that you put
forward first of all the the issue of
nuclear waste okay you you characterize
the picture of Yucca Mountain filling to
the brim etc etc when you think about
today's waste problem let alone future
okay we have one today especially
military wastes and so on do you have
something in mind do you have a vision
of how we will deal even if we didn't go
any further with nuclear how we'll deal
with the realities that we already face
as a practical matter what I expect us
to do and I'm not happy about it but I
think it's the only practical option
available we'll entomb the wastes on the
sites where they now are at the power
plants where they now exist in
formidable concrete casks which you
described actually in your remarks which
is the best interim solution I can think
of and Peter if it develops up to me I
wouldn't have launched all of this
without a clearer sense of what I was
going to do with the waste did here we
are but here we are and so I think what
we need to do now is concentrate on
safer storage on-site make it and also
on doing a better job of protecting the
relatively vulnerable and exposed pools
where a lot of the depleted fuel now
sits then what then it goes into the
casks Peter and then ultimately and then
what happens after that my hope
obviously is that after about a century
and here here I think I share your sense
of technological optimism we have a
better sense of what to do with it then
simply entombing it in Yucca Mountain
and sadly I think that's the best we can
do at the moment that is my strong
preference would be and I think the
lifetime of advocacy allows me to say
this my strong preference would be that
we have not begun this adventure but now
that we're here what I think we
absolutely must do is take more
seriously the risks associated with that
waste on site the potential temptation
it provides for people who don't wish us
well
and we need to do a better job and I
think this is an urgent national
priority for the regulators of
protecting that stuff okay let's move on
to one of the other issues which which
you you obviously got into which was the
issue of proliferation yeah okay so
today there are nuclear fuels moving
around the world there are countries
building reactors there are countries
who want to pursue the technology China
is probably the country where they're
building the most nuclear power plants
at the moment and expecting to at least
30 or so in light of the fact that there
is movement already toward further
nuclear power around the world toward
issues associated with proliferation
because not all those countries are
either stable or friendly right how do
we deal with the current realities of
proliferation because it's already in
issue there is no question that we ought
to do something that I think this
administration has conspicuously failed
to do which is to support and strengthen
the international safeguards associated
with the International Atomic Energy
Agency and yes absolutely and sadly
we've had we kind of developed a
national contempt in some quarters for
international institutions this is one
place where we desperately need them I
know everyone in this audience was as
delighted as you and I were that the
agency actually got the Nobel Peace
Prize this year so that's certainly
critical but Peter I I don't take it for
granted I think the question of how much
expansion there will be a worldwide
nuclear is still very much an open
question and depends a lot on what we do
nuclear powers actually lost market
share over the last decade in the sense
that yes some reactors have continued to
get built but the growth in reactors has
lagged way behind the growth in
electricity use so at the moment nuclear
power is a declining asset worldwide
there are a handful of centrally driven
economies the Anathem of everything
Peter Schwartz ever taught me where it's
still alive and relatively well but it's
not it's not flourishing at the moment
okay let's move on to the alternatives
yeah you you you made the observation
thousands of options right and so we see
here in California one of the great
success stories wind we've seen
efficiency but what about the other
renewables what do you see for the fate
of things like solar electric do are
they going to need the kind of subsidies
that we are getting forever well no I
think the no technology is well served
by being subsidized
and I think the California PUC in the
last week did exactly the right thing
with its solar program which is to
create a ten-year system of steadily
declining subsidies on a known
trajectory so the industry either stands
on its own at the end or fails and
there's constant pressure to reduce
costs and I think that's a good and the
payments are based on performance not on
how much it costs the suffering
homeowner to put the system in so you've
got a completely new paradigm for solar
in California now and it's an exciting
one and I hope many in this audience
will take advantage of it but Peter I
think the the options the other option I
would encourage you to look at more
closely because you are getting very
much locked into a paradigm where
electricity has to pick up all of the
slack on the transportation side it
seems to me at least possible that
biofuels can do a lot of this not the
biofuels of our traditional corn based
systems but a very significant shift
toward what is called cellulosic ethanol
where you're using the whole plant where
you can use agricultural wastes and
where you have a chance to add a very
interesting new option to a low-carbon
future and what's the economics of
cellulosic today well I I think there
it's very one can say very much the same
thing you're saying about imagine a new
reactor we don't know yet and so what I
hope we will do is give it a competitive
opportunity and set up and basically set
up what we if you look at what the PUC
has done the Energy Commission the basic
California approach to pushing all of
this stuff is you set up a limited
amount of subsidy you make everybody who
meets an environmental performance
criterion compete for that subsidy and
you base the winners of those who can
deliver value for the least amount of
subsidy that's a good approach we're not
locking in big chunks of money for
somebody regardless of how well they do
which heaven knows was the nuclear
approach for too long we're basically
saying it's a performance-based system
that rewards those who can deliver the
most at the least cost and that's the
way I'd like to see us go and with that
we are going on both renewables and
efficiency in California so when you try
to balance all these things the risks of
climate change the risks of rising
energy demand if we don't achieve huge
gains and efficiencies particularly
thinking into account China and India
and so on the risks associated with
technological failures and success we've
talked about a variety of technologies
nuclear wind solar cellulosic biofuels
efficiency so on they all have
technological risks associated with it
right do you judge the risks of one a
priori is greater than the other and
therefore we should bias the system and
so the most important thing for me is I
don't want to pick the winners and
losers and I don't want the government
to pick the winner I want the government
to set up a system that basically
establishes what the pollution control
rules are and then I want to allow for a
fair competition where you can actually
let these sub-options not many of it
which are not yet matured fight it out
Peter and what I hopefully will not do
is say there has to be a nuclear web
this size in order to solve the problem
what I hope we will do is to say this is
what it will take to solve the problem
these are the thing we most urgently
need now is we need the Congress of the
United States or failing that a
significant group of states to establish
binding limits on carbon dioxide
emissions that are known over time over
an extended period and that begin to
drive technology toward a low-carbon
direction at the lowest possible cost
and I hope all of us all of us could
unite in supporting that the good news
guys is that the Congress that this past
summer for the first time a majority of
the Senate went on record in support of
mandatory limits on carbon dioxide
emissions and that was the same Senate
remember that seven years earlier had
voted 96 to nothing against ever doing
anything like that for all time that's a
significant shift we should we should
capitalize on it okay
you talked about making it a fair
competition but obviously the government
determines a variety of things for
example the criteria ie which pollutants
co2 has been one of the big issues
government funds R&D the the nuclear
budget went to pretty close to zero as
the renewables went up what role for the
government in all this well I do think
it's fine to have a government R&D
budget Peter next my gentle disagreement
with you is I'm not sure
nuclear never went anywhere near as
close to zero for me I think it never
got below 100 million and it's now up
above 200 million and again the total
nuclear subsidies are the past 50 years
conservative estimate 150 billion
there's an argument to be made that
we've done enough R&D on this particular
technology but I think it's fine for the
government to try to help there's so
little private
Ardi on energy and so little technology
development if you look at the the
combined public and private investment
in creating better technology the United
States over the last quarter century
down about seventy-five percent when you
adjust for inflation we clearly need to
do more of that and I would not
personally object to seeing more of that
go into the possibility at least a
better reactors better fuel disposal
safer operation since we have a hundred
reactors right now we've got communities
around them we've got a stake in making
sure that they ramp down in a reasonable
and a prudent way what I don't like to
see is the government then stymie but
what I think that the error of the
energy bill was to go beyond that and
really begin to add a whole new set of
subsidies for operating reactors again
fifty years into the development of
technology when there's a real risk
Peter that that money won't go to the
exciting new technologies you're
envisioning but just one more round of
the old stuff that frankly hasn't been
remotely competitive every time there's
been a test wrapped on that part Peter
it's time for you to are you Ralph's
case okay well I think the the the
brilliance of you know it's really a
daunting experience to debate Ralph
Cabana I will say this I think my
colleague and friend over here put it
forward I think very eloquently the
problem is is clear we all see the
problem of radically reducing co2 I
don't think that there's any doubt about
the need to do that the question is how
do you make the choice among the options
and I think Ralph is arguing that the
system has been biased toward nuclear
and away from other options with
important exceptions like California
where we've run the experiment of what
happens when you mostly begin to get it
right where you begin to make a lot of
the choices about efficiency right you
begin to create the room for new options
to develop new technologies to come to
market in California as a very good
example of having done it right and that
in fact I think Ralph has an enormous
amount of confidence in the choices that
we would make if we were really exposed
to the realistic costs and risks and if
those were evident in the marketplace
and if all the options really
they're full costs as it were that the
more benign options like solar and wind
and efficiency would tend to win far
more often and that if nuclear actually
achieved similar levels of performance
while you could compete and win as well
and Ralph would have no objection to it
if it was meeting the same kinds of
criteria that in fact all the other
sources and including efficiency as
among them also had to meet Ralph is
profoundly skeptical that that could
ever occur that is in fact very fair and
appropriate thank you
I see kevin has an enormous stack he'll
bring some of the juicy wins up to me
shortly in the meantime I'll raise one
question which I noticed a slight
orthogonality to the comments from both
sides so far you spoke almost entirely
ralph's about the u.s. u.s. policy u.s.
experienced us competitive system Peter
you by and large spoke about a world
future really with a whole lot of China
and India in it with billions of people
coming out of poverty and coming into an
energy use level which is more like the
American one so in a sense I want both
of you to respond to that right I think
I would start with you Ralph because you
mostly deal National Resources Defense
Council mostly deals with US policy and
and so on if you were brought to you
tryna or to India as a consultant what
would you be telling well actually NRDC
deals very strongly with China as a very
strong China energy program and so
Stewart part of obviously is a global
problem and and I try to talking that
they're a hunt they're about about a
quarter of the world's nuclear
capacities in the United States I do
think that what the United States does
matters profoundly right now in terms of
helping to shape choices China for
example there is a China California
partnership in terms of how to organize
the utility sector and how to organize
competitive procurement of utility
resources susan kenedy of the California
PUC went to China to help explain the
new California energy efficiency
procurement systems to which could be of
course executed in a far larger scale in
China I still think therefore it is
terribly important to get it right here
as with with an eye toward the the power
that that model could have and I think I
guess this is something I'd be
interested hearing Peter sue I think the
the model of governments driving all of
the choices on energy resources is
actually one that's declining and likely
to go away that doesn't mean I am in no
sense a complete I don't have a kind of
a blind faith in markets in driving
these choices either
I like the hybrid model that California
exemplifies in which we have a lot of
government involvement in setting limits
and creating incentives and we have
regulated utilities doing a lot of
investment under competitive procurement
I think it's a nice hybrid between the
kind of the pure market model that many
of us remember with no nostalgia at all
from the mid-90s in California and the
totally centrally driven
command-and-control government systems
of Asia and France in this sector anyway
and and Peter do you really think that's
something that can endure for for long
in the as these as these countries
develop as they become more market
oriented as they become more
entrepreneurial can you keep the chains
around the system like that while Peter
is answering that Kevin can I have some
of those questions unfortunately I think
the answer is yes
a-a-a I wish it were otherwise I wish I
could say otherwise but I don't think
it's true look I think China's
centralized government is gonna be
around for a very long time I've call it
at least another 50 years certainly will
evolve and let go to some extent but I
think you're gonna have a Communist
Party basically it's a banded communism
call it whatever you want but it will
still run the national show including
things like big energy decisions you can
see how they're behaving with respect to
procuring resources abroad all right
they still might use competitive for
instance here in California one of our
most aggressive investors in efficiency
and renewables is the publicly owned
Sacramento Municipal Utility District
it's not an issue of public versus
private ownership it's an issue of
whether you're willing to use
competitive approaches to resource
procurement and they could come to that
but they are unfortunate I think the
challenge is so large when you start
thinking about how much coal they're
already projected to use you'd love to
have them get natural gas from Russia
but the Russia's just blew that last
week with their behavior with respect to
Europe and made themselves unreliable
suppliers do we want them to do more
Three Gorges well they already banned in
one rightly set of dams that they were
going to build so we're leaving them
with damn few options for that next four
or five hundred million people if we
push them away from nuclear power and we
don't want them to use all that nasty
coal I think that you know I don't see
how what they're going to do to supply
the electricity today they're mean why
is the pollution going up in why is oil
use going up in China then running
diesel generators in apartment buildings
because the electricity grid doesn't
work you know most do it let's let's go
on to your audience
Sam Ferguson is where they're in the
back raises question about uranium as a
fossil fuel given the uranium is pulled
out of the ground it exists there in
finite quantities is its use of uranium
and inherently temporary solution do you
know how long it will last
go ahead well it depends on how you use
it so it depends on the fuel cycle the
current u.s. fuel cycle is the least
efficient and would run through the fuel
if we expanded nuclear power in less
than a century but the truth is that we
have additional new fuel cycles where we
can reprocess the fuel reuse it
recapture the value and by the way
ultimately shift toward faster breeder
reactors probably a century or more in
the future where you have moved from
essentially a fuel cycle that consumes
fuel to one that actually makes fuel now
today that technology is both an
economic and probably dangerous so I
don't see that for at least a century
you don't need to get to it for a while
so we have time to move from inefficient
use to more efficient use to ultimately
being able to produce nuclear fuel but
the truth is essentially or more from
now the physics will have changed so
much who knows what we'll be talking
about but there is here a crucial and
important additional issue to raise the
reason the United States has had this
so-called once-through fuel cycle for
more than 30 years now as Peter is well
aware because of profound concerns about
the potential availability of weapons
material associated with the currently
available reprocessing methods and the
reason that we have declined to do this
for this extended period time and the
reason that so far at least the Congress
the administration have been unable to
overturn the policy is because I think
there remains a well justified and
genuine belief that the United States
until until the emergence of the
glorious new system that Peter continues
to hope for and I'm not ruling out but
until we can see clear evidence that
that's available and practical and
commercial we don't want to go down that
road for fear of creating yet a new set
of opportunities for nuclear weapons
proliferation of course it is the case
that almost none of our allies friends
or even competitors followed us in the
desire to not reprocess virtually every
other major country does already read
but happily none of them have it's in
every
I think an embarassment Peter it's not
economic it's propped up by massive
subsidies it's hard to hold it out as an
example of responsible or competitive
use of fuel I think the other point the
questioner is right - there are real
issues surrounding uranium mining in
terms of what it means in local enduring
local waste problems worker exposure we
haven't done that very well anywhere in
the world it's an additional it's an
additional it's it belongs on Peters
list of what we've got to do better if
there's not gonna continue on the other
side of the ledger we just saw the cost
last week of 13 miners lives in coal
mines last year was 22 in China it was
about 15,000 the 10,000 black lung
deaths
if 13 your nuclear power workers had
died in a nuclear power plant last week
we'd be shutting down every power plant
in the country a good reason not to
limit our choices to call the nuclear by
course one major state does it but all
I'm suggesting is that there are real
costs - in real lives to real people -
not developing the alternative to coal
here's a question it's nurse Kevin can
tell everybody in the room has put at
least one question congratulations this
one is from wo do you actually want to
wave your hand or stay anonymous
it's out there somewhere this is for you
ruff how long before we're carrying
placards that read no blood for
pollution credits
how will we enforce global compliance
with energy efficiency fuels and
actually it's it's a provocatively
phrased but wholly legitimate question
the the ultimate hope this is where I
think Peters remark about the Stone Age
is well taken the ultimate hope of
course after a century is that we are
doing all of these things because
they're better not because someone is
imposing the heavy hand of government to
make us do it but that the efficiency
and renewables options collectively
yield a more compelling system than the
one that we have now that we get for
those of us who believe in energy
efficiency the point is more in better
service not curtailment and sacrifice
the regulatory proposition is quite
different it seems to me if you look at
it that way this is why
California is so terribly important
because you see no one in the world
believes that we would impose on
ourselves any measure of self-sacrifice
for any purpose associated with energy
services if we actually if we actually
are capable of pulling this off together
that for me makes it an all all the more
compelling because I don't think in the
end that this works as a result of some
kind of worldwide police state making
sure no one is emitting any carbon I
mean I would just agree with that I
think by the way I do think the example
of what California does is important I
think some other states have followed
one could hope that someday Washington
will learn something from us a murmuring
in the audience that'll be the day
here's a question from Nicks nick
fox-gieg looks like you're here do you
believe that both of your proposed plans
an expanded nuclear program or an
expanded pollution credit regulatory
system requires us to reject the
currently popular notion that government
is not morally fit to set policy does
any energy solution to require the
repudiation of laissez-faire less safe
air disappearance there's another
question in here is can America bear to
look like France well but to the first
question you know it's it's hard to find
even among the most profound
anti-government skeptics it's hard to
find anyone who doesn't see a role for
government in pollution control I mean
less a fair has never worked
terrifically well in managing pollution
of shared air water and land resources
this is a government role that has a
pretty distinguished lineage and has
endured remarkably well through every
kind of administration the US has ever
had it's important emphasize therefore
that what I'm calling for is in my mind
an entirely logical extension of that
role and it's a limited one it says
basically that there will be limits on
how much can be emitted under those
limits obviously there is a flexible
system that allows winners and losers to
emerge on the merits I'm arguing that
carbon emissions automatic in the
economic competition that drives the
development and future of the world and
I'm arguing the United States should
lead in that effort I guess I would only
add to that I think look the truth is
there are wiser and better governments
and poor
and worse of governments and and and
unfortunately think it is very rare for
a very big government to be very wise
and farsighted and that's why I think
California is in some ways a more
interesting and relevant a laboratory if
you will such a small place well but if
it's meaningful
yeah its large enough to be meaningful
and where in fact the citizens and the
government can meet each other in a way
that you can't with the US government I
think Britain is doing interesting
things I think Tony Blair is doing
interesting things and oh by the way
what is Tony Blair thinking about these
days reviving nuclear power because he
got a wonderful free ride shifting from
coal to natural gas but the natural gas
is running out Margaret Thatcher got the
benefit of that gave him nice Kyoto
credits but he now says I don't want
more coal mines I don't want to reopen
the coal-fired power plants what am I
going to do when I start running out of
natural gas and oh by the way the
Russians are the only source I can see
coming with that and I don't like them
too much so he's reconsidering nuclear
power so even some of the wiser
governments at the scale of say the US
and the UK are thinking in those ways
this relates a question from Dave Bayer
it looks like the major population
states already possess nuclear weapons
capability so why should nuclear power
be taken off the table for about 75% of
the world population still coming like
China India Europe in the u.s. they have
the weapons already they have nukes
already I would add to this that if nuke
is so bad how come it isn't absolutely
shut down and add to that in the context
that particularly in Europe Peter
mentioned Britain also I gather sweden
finnland have been doing lately at least
nice liberal northern European countries
they're doing a turnaround on nuclear
and they're starting to seriously
reassess basically not only stopping the
the shutting down of their nuclear
program but that's starting to think
about expanding it well first I think
it's a mixed record I mean if you look
at Germany for example the conservative
head of government has just indicated
she is remains committed to shutting
down the rest of the fleet over the neck
20 years two German reactors are down
the other 17 are scheduled to go down
the politics and are different in
different places new I still say again
nuclear is lagging behind the growth in
electricity use it is steadily losing
market share it is in my mind a
declining resource that doesn't mean I
haven't tried to take it off the table
and I have said and mean that I think
going forward there's a continuing
competition we have to win we have to
produce better alternatives it's not
going to be all that tough in my opinion
and when I talk about proliferation I'm
talking about why if you look forward
and the toast is admonished us to look
forward 10,000 years one of the reasons
that I wouldn't mourn the loss of a
civilian nuclear industry worldwide is
simply to eliminate the convenient cover
that it provides that would be a plus
and I think there might be broad
agreement on that that doesn't mean it's
enough of a if it's enough of a plus to
plausibly suggest that everything shut
down tomorrow I think last summer I had
the privilege of actually raising this
question with Hans Blix
for those of you don't know Hans Blix
was the previous head of the IAEA and
the guy who really pissed off George
Bush enormous Lee with respect to the
so-called weapons of mass destruction in
Iraq I asked Blix how would you manage
this issue and he said look in his view
the proliferation issue is almost over
after Iran and North Korea which I think
we're unfortunately were going to be
unable to stop I think that genie is out
of the bag already I think the good
friends the Pakistanis made that
possible with AQ Khan but that having
been said there are not many other
candidates left in the world who have
either the financial wherewithal the
human talent wherewithal or the
motivation to do so we've had two
countries abandoned nuclear weapons
recently Libya especially before that
South Africa Brazil Mexico and so on I
mean the only guy who's begun to raise
the question again is Chavez in
Venezuela but when we look around the
world the truth is that the real
meaningful proliferation danger
unfortunately is the one that is already
at our doorstep and beyond that there
may not be our the others what Peter you
just said our only current problems are
North Korea Iran and Venezuela that
trivial and I just say you can't look
you can't know
10 25 50 years in the future it still it
would be better if the cover weren't
there I will hold to that without
suggesting that it ends the question
question from Garrett Gruner right down
here
neither speaker projected costs says
this former candidate for governor the
truth of the matter is that coal is
cheap and that with cost of co-team what
does heat speaker believe electricity
costs will be 30 years out well it's
what we both I think we're emphasizing
was we were we at least I wanted let me
not characterize Peters views he can do
that I'm thinking about a competitive
context in which electricity costs
absolutely matter and I am arguing that
part of what let's Auto let the winners
and losers emerge on the merits is what
is available at the lowest cost with
carbon part of the equation
I don't think coal coal the fuel is
relatively cheap coal the infrastructure
and coal the power plants is not cheap
at all and right now in the California
competitive procurements the resources
that I described are cleaning the clock
of both coal and nuclear and I expect
that to continue to happen in genuinely
competitive auctions in terms of what
that means for the future cost of
electricity it doesn't follow in my mind
that it has to come down it has to go up
rather dramatically remember that one of
the glories in particular the California
energy efficiency investments and let's
just celebrate the last four months we
launched the largest efficiency
investment program in the history of the
utility industry two billion dollars
over the next three years we did it with
an eye toward cutting the survey
electricity service cost and natural gas
service costs by about three billion
dollars the point of doing it was in
part to reduce energy service cost not
to increase them I don't accept the
proposition that the competitive systems
that I am advocating and the options
that I think are going to continue to
emerge and continue to flourish mean
we're going to have to pay more for
energy services you could be right and
and I hope you're right but I have a
feeling that we're the price is gonna go
up and I think the reason is several
fold first of all I Garrett's right Cole
he appears to be cheap but of course it
doesn't bear the full environmental cost
and so I think it is very likely
that we are going to adjust the fuel but
we are going to do well but now we're
going to add cost to the power plant as
well in other words we're going to add
cost to the power plant by capturing the
co2 and then ultimately sequestering it
and that will bring coal to a position
close to competitive with nuclear power
and with potentially solar as well so
what we're going to find is that those
kinds of fuels are going to get more
expensive I think wind will continue to
get cheaper you know we're gonna be able
to build more and wind is already very
competitive and that's why you see in
Germany and and in the u.s. lots of wind
going in except where they're being
blocked by environmentalists of course
in places like Massachusetts New York
and West Virginia because they don't
like the sight of them or in Alameda
County because one windmill kills one
bird every four months and so we want to
and we've shut down our windmills for
four months in Alameda because of
concern about Raptors appropriate
concern but everything has its risks and
its trade-offs that's the point and the
cost therefore begins to go up at that
point when we start building in those
things so you don't run the windmills 12
months a year you only run them eight
months a year so they're operating their
net cost and effect goes up so all of
these things we'll see I think pressures
on cost eventually efficiency I think
goes the other way that I agree with you
that will continue to get cheaper and
cheaper in a great variety of ways here
a couple of questions for you and one
from Wendy Maria Phelps here do you
believe that citizens throughout the
world should have the Democratic
Democratic opportunity to decide if they
want nuclear power plants and/or wastes
in their community
absolutely but he doubt about that I
think that's fundamental notion of
democracy I don't think the doubt about
that and then Stephen Fowler asks could
Peter expand on his claim that the earth
could only support two billion people
under the scenario where the world
atmosphere temperature increases by five
percent I think what is it what I said
was that if the earth returns to its
normal climate which is the result of a
radical shift and an end of the
interglacial where the world will be
much colder and more volatile the
ability to essentially produce enough
food and have enough water of
for eight billion people is what is the
issue we saw for example eight thousand
two hundred years ago a brief period
where the climate of the world went down
about 5 degrees stay down for a century
and came back up and what you saw
throughout the whole northern hemisphere
was a world that was much drier much
colder much windier for roughly a
century whole civilizations disappeared
in that interregnum of a broken climate
this has happened a number of times in
history where we've seen these kinds of
sudden shifts in the climate and they
produced catastrophic change in our
ability to supply food and water to the
population so that's what the real issue
here is that if we return to that world
of colder and more volatile it the the
mechanism of transmission of the
consequences are through the water in
the food system see a little more I'm
carrying capacity dropping for humans
that one third of what it is now is that
how does that actually work out but what
happens is that the northern climates
basically north of about 20-25 degrees
so think well south of here we're about
35 so think Southern California Mexico
that's sort of everything north of that
becomes progressively difficult to
sustain agriculture and that's where we
grow most of our food in terms of food
and water do you buy that by the way oh
yeah this is for me one more I don't
know for sure but it's one more reason
why I don't want to run the experiment
one hour longer than is absolutely
necessary well see and one hour longer
of one of the questions here is lag
times even one of the attractions of
efficiency is you can do start doing it
right now and the costs are pretty low
every time you lower the increments one
of the problems with nuclear is that
there's enormous like x huge capital
expenses typically Alexander Rosa's
reminding me before this evening of
decades of permissions and then of
building and then more time before it
finally comes online are those like
times the serious issue here
absolutely there are several lags that
are important what one is just a
decision in construction time so I think
we can radically reduce that and if we
do what they do in France where it's
about four or five years instead of
twelve years the cost of nuclear Falls
dramatically so we can deal with that
but I'm less concerned with those lags
than I am with the fact that we've got
built into our
system already an enormous amount of
momentum of co2 production even if we
went all out to shift cars all out the
shift power plants and coal and so on
there are decades yet still of co2
production that will grow before we
begin to turn it down so I think it's
that lag which I'm more concerned about
it's why I want to make the shift away
from co2 intensive fuels as fast as
possible because the lag is so large in
fact the existing system I agree with
his last point Stewart not with the
first the fact is that the lead times
and scale of resources matters enormous
Lee in terms of their relative
competitiveness and so far this has been
a real Achilles heel of nuclear it is
just too big too cumbersome it takes too
long
given the multitude of nimbler
competitors I would just say on the wind
being one of the nimbler competitors I
don't want to let the last comment go
wholly unanswered peter is right that
some in the environmental community have
raised concerns about the possible
damage to birds and bats associated with
wind development particularly in the
Altamont Pass which has the highest
concentration of wind machines in in
North America and which was cited more
than 20 years ago having just spent two
days with those advocates meeting
directly with the renewable energy
community I came away with it with a
clear sense that the effort of those and
there are many in this room who for
example are members of local Audubon
chapters is not to shut down wind
resources but to make sure we know more
about the ways that they could
potentially interfere with bird and bat
migrations and do something responsible
in the siting in the design of the
machines to minimize the harm and I
think that's a reasonable thing to do
when I predict it will not in the end
materially affect the deployment and and
the contribution of wind power well
Peter you mentioned that there's a lot
more carbon loading going on as we speak
and then many of these atmospheric
cycles are already in progress
Toby Sanderson has a question if the
Earth's climate is so inherently
unstable and we are currently going
through a period of relative stability
what effect can we have on climate if it
will naturally descend into a chaotic
state anyway I would add to this a
couple of weeks ago we had Freeman Dyson
on the stage and
he said right out loud he thought the
models about global warming were
interesting but only models and the
actual role of what humans are doing on
that is to him still questionable he
thinks warming is absolutely going on
and I guess the question here is is
climate so large that whatever we do
it's going to go its own way and it
could be pretty strange in any case
that's certainly possible look it is a
system that is extremely complex my
background is fluid mechanics I'm
actually a rocket scientist I get to say
that and fluid mechanics was my
specialty and there's a turbulent
complex fluid and it is hard to predict
in fact I built some of the first global
climate models in the 1970s when I was
at SR I did the first global climate
assessment for the US government when
the issue was global cooling because the
world had cooled from 1960 to 75 and we
were all worried about another little
ice age so the models are genuinely
questionable however we do have a fair
amount of data on a what the long-term
dynamics are and what some of the
important physical dynamics associated
with those are for example to buildup of
greenhouse gases and ralph said it well
we're at levels of greenhouse gases that
have simply never been experienced
before and particularly co2 and no we
cannot be certain that a we are causing
it but the odds are that we are
contributing to it substantially because
of the level of co2 and a few other
greenhouse gases and that the risk here
is that if you put that much gas that
much co2 in the atmosphere it absorbs
enough energy that it triggers a change
that might otherwise take thousands of
years might play out in decades and it's
it's as you put more energy into the
atmosphere it becomes more volatile it
is able to has more excursions much
greater dynamics more extreme storms
more extreme weather and so on and so it
is those dynamics that build up and
produce the kind of flip and change of
state that we are worried about and and
for those of us who have not been
schooled in fluid mechanics and I have
to acknowledge it didn't figure
prominently in the curriculum of the
Law School I still think it's legitimate
to say this after having heard Peter
described the nature of what's happening
to the atmosphere and the potential
consequences if you thought about this
as an experiment you were being asked to
authorize collectively in your names is
there any reason why you would vote to
do this as a kind of an interesting
excursion in global fluid dynamics and
if you can't see a reason to take these
risks isn't a plausible conclusion that
we ought to see if it's possible to stop
the experiment at reasonable cost and I
think really that's what this entire
discussion is about the fusion question
comes from Tracy sweat law it looks like
something like that are you aware of any
real practical research being done to
develop fusion technology do you believe
it is a viable possibility start the
period there's a lot of money going into
fusion but is it practical is another
question you know the famous saying
about fusion which unfortunately is true
is that 30 years ago fusion was 40 years
off and today Fusion is 40 years off and
probably 40 years from now fusion will
be 40 years off the physics of this is
really hard but I think we've basically
probably got it wrong I don't think
we're gonna put a little magnetically
bottle hunk of the Sun in a reactor and
produce power with it that's been most
of the current thrust there's a huge new
project underway in Europe that we're
contributing to and so and I think it's
basically an employment process for
physicists and and I guess I'm somewhat
more humble in this and on this and a
whole host about it what I've learned in
this area is there every technology has
at least one absolutely convinced
theologian who will at any public
gathering arise and to claim it as the
final solution and look I'm prepared to
acknowledge that all of these things
might play a role I think in the end it
will be a portfolio that gets us through
not a single option course I think we
would be unwise to rule anything out
definitively now and equally unwise to
assume that somehow any of these options
is sufficiently compelling that
particularly the ones that are several
decades out so there should be a crash
government program to develop it and my
concern about nuclear right now is there
does appear to be at least the
beginnings of a movement among some of
our political leadership to try to do
something like that fortunately they
don't have enough money
and so I think it's unlikely that
they'll pull it off and there will be
all these distractions like we could do
fusion and you'll end up with a
relatively well diversified R&D program
and you do hope a few good things come
out of it let me just ask both of you to
kind of listen we're heading toward wrap
up here at catalog what look to you like
promising emerging technologies this is
a group that's been living with Moore's
law for most of their adult lives and
you know we've had good reason to expect
breakthroughs and technology you say
that physics is going to keep on
changing you see the renewables getting
more and more efficient carbon
sequestration is on the table but it's
kind of a hand wave in many respects so
far so I'd love to get a kind of a
Shoppers guide to basically kinds of
technology you would like to see really
go forward and this might be our MP from
the government it might be a great
opportunity in the private sector some
of them might be things which just
completely change the game which it
sounds like we would all like because as
much as you like nukes it's not busy
like nukes is because what you just like
a lot of the other things going on you
know what could blow nukes off the table
for you what could really augment
conservation and renewables for you or
else so what's what's on your mind is
things to pursue look if you could get
solar much more efficient than it is and
much cheaper I mean that would be an
enormous advantage in other words if you
can capture a much greater fraction of
the incident solar radiation and do it
cheaply that would be a really really
good thing
energy storage for making renewables
work energy storage is a very important
technology we don't have many good ways
today batteries you know that's you can
compress air you can pump water there's
a variety of things you can do but all
of those have problems if you have much
better storage you have many more
options for use of renewables the grid
if you have a grid that is more
sophisticated that enables you to
dispatch renewables use renewables and
sophisticated ways and distributed ways
that would
be a big advantage I think part of the
issue here is that there are many things
that have to happen for all of that to
work well to be able to make a big
substitution for all of the coal and the
nuclear that we have today the base load
electricity that is there all the time
that runs all the time requires a kind
of systemic change that requires a
number of these technologies to
integrate in a way that they don't yet
today and I think that integration
process is another whole level of
technology not just simply the physical
technologies themselves to be able to
create a kind of grid that sustains the
the system 24 hours a day everywhere
that it needs to be you're a political
issues some of both there are technical
issues in how you manage and operate the
grid and then there are political issues
in in who runs it under what
circumstances and so Stewart let me
identify a couple of additional things
that might work even more quickly we I
think we should do a lot more with
research and development in building and
vehicle efficiency at the national
budget for building efficiency is about
seventy million dollars which isn't
enough to build one building that
strikes me as a tragic miss allocation
of resources I also mentioned the
possibility of bright biofuels
breakthrough in cellulosic ethanol made
from plant wastes rather than from corn
Peters in my mutual friend Vinod Khosla
believes very strongly that if we can
just get a proliferation of flexible
fuel vehicles so the Californians have
the option of filling up with pure
ethanol in addition to gasoline as
Brazilians now do that it could make a
profound difference and if you those of
you who follow events in Brazil will see
that there's a very interesting
experiment going on there I'll close
with one that will surprise you I think
on the coal side we we need to mention
the fact that there is at least
beginning to emerge some signs of a
possible revolution in the way that coal
is used and this is processes that don't
burn it but in effect refine a gas out
of it and then have a pure stream of
carbon dioxide that you could pump
underground much more readily and
cheaply than is possible now that
becomes relevant if you look at the size
of the coal resources in India and China
and Stewart has admonished me to think
about them the fact is that if all the
coal plants now propose to get built in
the next 25 years are in fact built and
they burn coal in conventional ways they
more carbon dioxide over their lifetime
the next 25 years worth of coal plants
worldwide than all of the carbon dioxide
emissions in the recorded history of
humanity and if that happens we can't
suspend the global climate experiment so
it seems to me we have an interest in
testing that proposition whether there's
a new way to use coal that makes it
dramatically easier and cheaper to
dispose responsibly of the wastes and
that ought to be on the table at least
as much in my view as the nuclear option
should be on the table i I agree with
that very strongly you know I think the
numbers you put forward I think are
really quite striking and think about
this if every Chinese today used energy
the way the average American uses energy
that would equal all of world energy
demand in other words if they got to the
same level as us we have to double the
world energy production happily they
have tighter fuel economy standards yes
already let's play another future game
here Peters already said that it's a
whole bunch of stuff going on with the
climate you seem to agree with that the
experiment we can't unring that Bell
experiments already in progress
we can stop it we could slow it and
there are legs 20 years on climate
continues to get weirder more in bigger
hurricanes of rising levels not only in
the Maldives and Bangladesh but right
here in San Francisco Bay weirder
weather of species dying hither and yond
they go up to the top of the mountain
because it's changing and then there's
no more mountain and they what you know
this is already happening in a large
degree ok it gets worse and worse and
worse several administrations have gone
by in the u.s. in the UN the UN has
turned over a bunch of people they've
been wars and non wars various places in
the world the Chinese economy has done
whatever it's going to do the end of the
economy has done what it's ever going to
do and climate is the big event for
everybody then how do these questions
play out for both of you
well it's it in in that world Stuart for
me climate achieves a political salience
that it is only starting
to have now but what I think that what I
would expect then is that it will there
will be a political imperative to have
effective national limits on emissions
of greenhouse gases there will be
enormous it's already starting to build
but it will only be growing every
hurricane season the entire American
population will be reminded that
hurricanes are gigantic heat engines and
that that is an additional reason to
care passionately about these issues and
and what I hope it will do therefore
this is the positive side of it is this
is all driving innovation and that is
the collective hope that Peter and I
have we have some more different views
of where that will go if it goes where I
hope it will I think it will ultimately
leave us in a better place if those
kinds of concerns are harnessed that
this is part of what good leadership is
going to be all about it will take and
we made there to hope some of it is here
in this audience some people who are
prepared to step up and lead on that
rather than just wring their hands and
complain about it or assign it to
sunspots or random natural variations
that none of us could I think that the
terrible temptation will be to somehow
suggest that there's nothing we can do
and that we have no culpability and
there I think I mean you gave us a rare
reason to suspect Freeman Dyson of human
human culpability a moment ago I think
the overwhelming scientific consensus is
different and that it will be
increasingly difficult for responsible
politicians to take that view you know
look I think we can get there but we've
already seen some of this play outs to
it we can see it historically when after
the first oil crisis second oil crisis
in 1979-80 the United States passed for
the first time mileage standards the
cafe standards and and Ralph remember
that originally it was intended that
after about five years six years through
was played out was supposed to go up
again the original legislation said it
was going to be twenty seven and a half
and then in 1987 at the instigation of
the president was supposed to go on up
to 35 if we were honored right
trajectory Ronald Reagan cancelled that
did not implement 235 if we had
implemented 35 miles per gallon standard
we'd have two million barrels a day of
oil imports today and we wouldn't care
very much about Venezuela or Saudi
Arabia or a number of other places and
our emissions would be much much lower
and oh by the way GM and Ford might be
thriving because of course Toyota took
that challenge serious
and GM went from a market share of 50%
to 25% and Ford from 30% to 14 percent
while Toyota tripled its market share
selling green cars to Californians and
so I think there are if we get these
choices right you don't get to that
place now the interesting and weird
thing that I'll throw one wrinkle into
this whole thing I think you could even
see as painful as this means to say the
Bush administration changed their
position on climate change bring us back
in two years as as my family knows we
were on vacation recently each morning
and we were in a remote location I wake
up and check the New York Times faxes
Dick Cheney still alive but having said
that I keep hoping having said that this
is going out over the radio Peter I
understand I understand there is I think
what we see here is a real failure that
I think they've actually begun to
recognize the world is aligned against
them the scientific community is aligned
against them even their own scientists
have aligned there's only two people in
America who don't believe in climate
change it's George Bush and Dick Cheney
you know the Department of Defense
believes that the Department of Energy
believes that EPA believes it you know
there's a small cabal of two guys who
don't and and I think I think there's a
question about Karl Rove I mean yeah
I'll put Karl in the envelope in the
bubble but having said that my point is
that even in the administration you're
beginning to see the forces beginning to
shift and the politics of this could
begin to change significantly even
before imagine what the Republicans do
to the Democrats if they take away the
environmental issue and Peter what will
drive that and there's some in this room
who are trying to make it happen I think
it's actually the business community yes
exactly and leading on this and I think
there in this room I know are for
instance people from the Silicon Valley
leadership group who have been for
Silicon Valley giving them strongest
possible constructive example of the
potential
ways that our technology leadership
could generate solutions and a
remarkable lack of fear in that
community about the potential of
responsible regulation and I do think
that's going to get through to even the
most cloistered sections of the
environment I hope that the
administration sometime soon we put
10,000 years in the title and we should
probably end in that timeframe 10,000
years Farley King because it actually
came from Peter I'll give you the
history of this 10,000 years story the
long now foundation was named by Brian
Eno and then we were trying to decide
how long is the now that we're
interested in and Schwartz came up with
how about everything since basically
agriculture when towns first began
civilizations story got going that was
about 10,000 years ago so we'll take the
last 10,000 years the next 10,000 years
that's the long now one of the reasons
the number of us went to visit at Yucca
Mountain is its timeframe is 10,000
years that was set by Congress back in
the 1950s as the amount of time that
they were supposed to be responsible for
the nuclear waste there it's very
bizarre things happen you know we could
talk about that but that's probably
another evening what are we talking
about climate in 10,000 years nuclear
power and the timeframe of 10,000 years
what is that perspective do to both of
your positions you know there's no doubt
that the Earth's climate will be
different 10,000 years from now than it
is today
there's no period in human history of
stability of 10,000 years that has never
happened I would have 20,000 years so
it's going to change it's gonna change
there will be change in the climate the
question is do we have in that period of
time have we gotten smart enough to both
be participants in that process as well
as to learn how to live with that
process do we have an understanding of
ecosystems of biology do we have
technological resources and and the
truth of the matter is I think there's
no doubt of that
I think we are going through a
transition that is probably several
centuries like it or not where we have
mu
moved from a world where nature
controlled us to where we understand and
frankly control nature in ways that we
simply have never had before and so
before the end of this millennium I
think our relationship to the natural
environment our relationship to the
climate will change fundamentally and so
that by ten thousand years from now we
will be active participants in
co-creating in a kind of positive sense
what the climate is and I will make two
observations on this one is that a
federal court recently invalidated the
ten thousand year rule for nuclear waste
on the ground that it wasn't a
sufficiently long period to deal with
the waste given its toxic
characteristics underscoring further
however you feel about the merits
decision Stuart think is perfectly
dreadful it does underscore the
political challenge of part of the topic
this evening but look the main thing I
would want to emphasize too it is on
this issue and I think everyone in this
room is aware of this but I want to
underscore it in closing we don't have
ten thousand years we probably don't
have ten if if we do not begin to move
decisively to suspend or at least slow
the global climate experiment in the
years immediately ahead then my concern
is the ten thousand years out the
experiment has seen its way
very possibly through to some very
unpleasant conclusions that we could
have done something about if we had been
more effective in our efforts over the
next ten years let's not allow ourselves
to have that regret however far out
Stuart allows us to go and let's stay
focused is at least for par I'm
delighted to have a forum that
occasionally looks out ten thousand
years but I don't want you to have the
luxury of thinking you've got anything
like that long to get serious about this
problem
[Applause]
[Music]